yo this podcast is brought to you by on
it go to anicon right now and press in
church and get 10% off delivered right
to your house the best supplements in
the market number two why you paying so
much for razors you're going to
supermarket or pharmacy razors or IPs it
ends tonight for a limited time I'm
going to hook you up with Dollar Shave
Club new members get their first month
of executive razor with a tool with dr.
Carla shea butter which is the best for
only 5 hours with free shipping no
hidden fees no commitments do me a favor
go to dollarshaveclub.com right now
slash church and I'm going to get you
that deal the first month executive
razor with the tool but dr. coffee shea
butter for five dollars number three
listen everybody's buying these
expensive watches and they're all nice
and pretty and stuff but listen why are
you doing that to yourself I get your
movement watched and a rock your world
pronounce MB and T watches they started
$95 at the department store you're
looking at for the $500 you understand
me today I'm gonna get you 15% off with
free shipping and free returns by going
M VMT watches calm / Church one more
time and VMT back Tom's last Church
dollarshaveclub.com / Church and audit
dot-com / Church like a [ __ ]
here we go oh [ __ ]
what Monday what what hey
twenty-something don't [ __ ] matter
you're here
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] in the morning crack of
dawn it's like cold out my see who's
this paging me the shop block people
please chill drop to Cleveland got nice
with god damn that sounds good mom
wouldn't disrespect are you [ __ ] nuts
the Church of what's happening now when
Christopher kid Reid made man Lisa I yes
here we go do you win by slow oh oh oh
tell me what you're going to do you're
brilliant you bad [ __ ] what
wouldn't this was back happy Tuesday
Christopher kid Reid in the house my
main man the two things at Monday Monday
but they're here Tuesday so problematic
and my main men on the drums Lisa at
looking good
hello sir Hawaii leaves a bad mother if
he was if he was a monster they were
calling what would they can't leave the
kill would you like that I think very
high nearly was a gangster usually
lately that's a nice compliment you said
you always climb the way that I got with
[ __ ] were smaller than you
always that's what people never realize
you don't have to be a genius games on
three guys are smarter than you and you
could take over a [ __ ] a kingdom you
know my father used to tell me stuff
like that my father
old-school Jamaican me just see just
turn 89 and he would tell me like
sometimes you can see me with my friends
he said I see here with your friends and
sometimes you know you're the one have
it going on the most you know you're the
smartest yeah I have it going on you're
bringing them up that's a good thing
you're bringing them up but who bringing
you up like who do you hang with that's
smarter than you that's doing better
than you that you know I'm saying like
people get too
take from your your ocean but where do
you refill it at you know I mean that's
why I started hanging about you know so
I hang with people like Bill Maher like
hanging people smarter than me and you
know just different stuff you know I'm
saying right I think what a depressing
way to start this interview I think it
was you to do say Bill Maher but really
about three weeks later I got an
audition and I swear to God I get there
there's a bunch of Italians in the room
with Sopranos was on fire right they
couldn't control this [ __ ] right leaked
so I get down and I see Sebastian
Maniscalco at that time Sebastian didn't
talk much Sebastian was very introverted
very shy even more so than Chris Rock
likey buddy just don't talk right and I
take sabbatical Sebastian going there
with me he was hanging out with the
wrong level but this audition he wasn't
gonna get dick if you went in there
without easily haha and I knew it I was
looking like big [ __ ] I was on fire
right grabbed him and we went in then we
mailed it there was me Sebastian and
somebody else that we knew so right
three brothers that we knew fact and
they told us don't shake no mores and
all that [ __ ] and all sudden Omar came
over started talking to us yeah you know
talking about some girl on the set he
was very sweet he asked us if we ate you
know we had 300 hours for that he's not
be talk to us he I thought wasn't make
like $10,000 I went down to like I
booked an ABC promo I'm gonna make ten
Jesus [ __ ] my agent like you made 305
yeah and where's mine
I need [ __ ] fruit story right but it
was a good look right you gotta take you
got a tape exists somewhere you know me
people that listen to it go go look for
that cuz yeah I mean I I did a sketch of
a back then yeah man you know what dude
like I said who's been you've been a
good he's been a good friend to me and
you know not just on the professional
but the personal and you know for years
you know we had the you know his theme
on on HBO's real time you know that I
sent them since I gotten dunks on
something but I'm thinking don't touch
you ever done something great
yeah that's you out there doing if you
don't stop yeah I mean me and my two
good buddies Buster and Giovanni you
know what this is the thing um you know
when you know when
left ABC you know it was under a couple
incorrect but I mean bring her back
they're looking for a house right now
well they need I mean that'd be great if
they did it but then they gotta give him
a check I got it you know that my point
was he had got fired from politically
incorrect
you know everybody thought he was you
know he was you know those are tough
days you know what I'm saying you know
we were talking you know he was you know
he was low but they got back on at HBO
they got to show they got real-time and
one day I just hit him up okay man you
know like you got it you got a theme
song for your new show with HBO it
should be like some cool [ __ ] you know
saying I was like yo the only other one
I had done was I did it for my boy
Martin Lawrence for the TV show you know
my my cuz I was my boy you know I mean
that's kind of how I work I was like yo
you know you got a you got a song and he
had a song so he's a young man he do to
the song for it and he played it for me
it was just and it was awful and I was
like man let me and my boys get some of
that you know I'm saying because you
know this HBO man it's cool you can cuss
and the main thing was just musically
you know you got to get across to people
and get across the people you work with
say hey man the music we create the way
you rock when you hear your theme song
people gotta know the truth is coming do
you mean so this thing is that's what
errors interesting like that and if you
think about it he's the only comedian
that has his own theme song like lots of
us come out to music you know like
George Lopez comes out to lowrider but
that's not his song you know he copped
it when you hear that Bill Maher team's
only only person you think about is him
wrong
I make sense right but anyway but I
digress back to you my friend what's up
baby boy is interesting to see ya but we
had oh really started like I'm a big nut
sound like it that's not likely that's
all that we did about sound like
something we should've did like 40
better-known
I I'm a big but you're Sherlock so how
you are how I never thought of that that
you called them and said yours is the
truth and I want your music to come up a
little bit yeah I mean like really I
mean like I mean you know what I came in
this game you know people know us you
know
kid kid and play and the hair and the
dancing and the movies and all that but
we came in the game or I came in the
game on the music tip and you know you
know we're both from New York and you
know it was just a you know we got
exposed to everything man so you know
like we were talking about it like man
you know we grew up in with the school
with all kinds of people with school
with white people we knew all their
music and our music and we got exposed
to everything you remember AM radio back
in the days like you don't know what
you're a musician
WABC you're a waiter with a button you
got $25,000 like wait wait but what was
the the playlist the play you can hear
are really old J's then you can hear
captain into Neil and then you could
hear Billy Preston and then you can hear
the miracles and then you could hear oh
yes they call it the street look at that
look at that fan bang on two feet
remember that remember them we got a
great big convoy honking through the
night we got a great big convoy so we're
together you'd be I'm telling you man
but people forget these novelty records
man like and they would be a my rock
they would be right in the mix right
after that and then after that you you
know you hear like that all right so
when you grew up what Stacy did you grow
up listening to WCW ABC with the you
know that were the foundation and then
I'm one of the black stations WB 11 BLS
there were two steps to the ring get out
of here
oh no the wind later please oh my
Frankie Crocker that's how those little
church rock off record Rocco he
described W then there I go Michael
there I go you're going to play that
pull that sword on Sundays we was a lot
of that song yeah yeah you could do that
Knight was uh on Sunday nights was the
church you could be what you want to be
what you want to do although the
preacher and have what you want to have
a remember I could every night I used to
get placed on Sunday night because
Reverend Ike would show up on WBLS then
I would have to switch over to [ __ ]
you're gonna watch which I was dumb
money and he W and you got the King
Biscuit flower hour and he would
interview people when you learn right
you know so very interesting here in the
beginning when I came from Cuba whatever
my mother played at the house is what I
grew up on the doors
at first she used to rock out I like two
doors and she liked Spanish music right
but then I was against Hispanics music
but when I started hanging out a lot in
48th Street those little Rican
[ __ ] got me into salsa any all
stars and all that [ __ ] so now I'm eight
good stuff listen to our Latin seven
eight and eight most kids Allah says I
wouldn't even listen to American music
right and I would listen to the radio at
the house then about ten was when I got
my first I told long-haired people with
creepy [ __ ] right like [ __ ]
that long as they are those people
around me right coming from along here
yes my long hair went up in the air this
is 1970 like I was against long hair the
whole thing when I started hearing that
type of music that was my closet music
right
white blood Zeppelin was the chalice
into a loan and it was a buddy's - no I
wasn't no I did that - yeah y'all go
ahead I'm and I'm half white so you know
doing so it's a beautiful thing that you
I grew up on everything yeah yeah you
know what's up on average I did and you
know growing up um you know let you know
I'm Jamaican and Irish so you know which
means I get high and drunk by the way
but what is what it meant was it meant
for a real you know like you said we
listen Terry and then you know what
thank God you know we grew up where we
grew up
you know I'm saying like New York is
going to give you a dose of everything
you know if you've just walking down the
block
hearing music from different cars and
stuff like that so we grew up on that
but there was something about something
about that hip hop that that we
gravitated towards you know
I mean like we weren't we weren't like
traditional singers or stuff like that
like an we grew up we love that R&B era
you know me we love that Teddy
Pendergrass and we love that old days
and all that but something about that
hip-hop when it started popping it spoke
to us you know what I mean and me I was
like an English major I was like a
little but I thought I was a little
writer you know and I was like yeah like
you know I feel like I can do this like
I can be clever and whatever and I
remember I remember the first rhyme that
I wrote first rhyme I was 14 years old
freshman I was I was I went to Bronx
High School of Science
all right mu break this can I break can
I break it down this is the first time
first time I ever wrote you always like
the first one is like the first piece of
[ __ ] you ever got your memos emcees
they remembered a first round even if it
sucks okay all right this is my first
run uh-huh
Joe I was on the train coming home from
school when I seen this freak that made
me drool man he's going freak girl was a
freak okay right
good there's some freaks in the church
right but it came back though it went
away they came back you know saying I
was on the train coming home from school
when I seen this freak that made me
drool you see this freak hat on a little
cut dress that plainly showed the pus
that was the best so I got off my seat
and sit down next to her till this fine
young free she was a fine young girl she
rewarded me with the invitation to her
house and with that exclamation I told
her I'd be glad to come but one thing
first I got call my mom tell her that
I'll be home real late tell her not to
worry and not to wait about right y'all
you don't know how do you remember
that's amazing let me ask you this bro
first 119 you're 14
who's rapping already who's rapping when
you're 14 it's 19 is 77 maybe it's 78 78
78 who's rapping people in my
neighborhood because our rapper's
delight'
I don't think I came out 80 79 I mean
yeah it was I mean yeah you know
rapper's delight' was the first like
quote-unquote you know rap record but we
was already rapping you know I was
rapping you know 78 78 79 it was you
know it was you know we were getting it
on on on literally on cassette tapes you
know Grandmaster Flash and the Furious
Five you know break out in the funky for
Grandmaster Caz and and you know the
fearless you know all these you know did
was just cruise but but the first one
the bus was you know what they had to ha
the hip and but as New Yorkers we was
like but it was all we had you know I
mean so yeah we was into it it was it
was real or tribal in neighborhood or
you know what I mean like you was you
was a local legend but outside of you
know like we you know coming up in
Queens you know I mean I was born in the
Bronx but me and play grew up in Queens
together you know we was just trying to
be a legend in our neighborhood you know
what I'm saying
and that's that's what we did and play
and I were like in different groups like
he was in one group and I was in another
group we were like rivals at first so
you know we would try to do all friends
but we all you know we trying to you
know how it is like you try to bust you
boys that you know you even had comics
you know saying like yo I moved you mean
I was my boy but you know man who runs
in Queens did you ever bump into DMC in
the early early days no no never
confused
no no because they were ahead of us like
they were like I mean those guys are
legends those are guys or queens legends
like if we ever caught sight or they
busted out like an 82 83 yeah yeah so by
the time yet so by the time by the time
you know yeah I'm just graduating high
school then like I remember god I
remember me and I remember playing on
going up to the fever yellow fever
uptown disco fever right sala Botello in
the disco fever you know that's that's
where they base cross group out of and
all was the famous club in the Bronx
right so we like hell man we got you
know no we just took the train up there
man you know we're just trying to be
around if we hadn't blown up or anything
we were nobody but we just had to be
around that man we've seen we've seen we
saw a run up in that [ __ ] like
me
was a legend man run those guys are the
guys that we idolize that we were trying
to be like run D and C Houdini
you know Kurtis Blow you know the Fat
Boy go them guys was ahead of us man and
and they was they were doing different
[ __ ] like fat boys was blending into the
movies you know Krush groove you know
Kurtis Blow you know Run DMC I mean come
on man who was digging in Run DMC in 80
and 85 you know cook Cool J Cool J was
blowing up then and these all these
cattle are mostly catchable queens man
the sad thing is that I remember talking
to you now I'm a little [ __ ] up
because you are could you you don't use
it you got that you ate the edibles no
no no but I remember go get about I
remember going to them different like
listen I copped on Jerome Avenue on
Wednesdays it was a joint day on
Thursday you go to Queens because the
guy had the bullet I yeah on Tuesday you
went to the Bronx you got a slice of
pizza at that place because that guy was
there selling weed on Monday you went to
178 Street and on Saturday and Sunday
you went to 135th Street so I would go
to all these different boroughs and when
you're walking these barrels you would
hear like you said your sensory you hear
all of these [ __ ] sounds and I'm sure
I remember hearing like early rap and
going what the [ __ ] is this
so was there to the fire when you need
him really oh yeah but see that's what
my mentality was so I did it caught on
like I write he were the hair was on
yeah we had we had we know you know it's
like like my kids today like and and you
know people the Millennials they don't
know a life where hip-hop didn't exist
we do we do we had one foot in the old
world and then came into the new world
you don't I mean we remember they when
it wasn't you know what I mean and so it
was unique I mean I appreciate it now
but you're right they would there was a
time when your old man just give me some
[ __ ] Earth Wind and Fire give me the
whispers give me the OJS give me the
Tabares you know what I'm saying
who done it who stole my lady
who
on it everyone and ruler change whodunit
that's no matter from bees way to Christ
go get wisdom dal-rae we get in let me
ask you something like I don't remember
here right the Millennials don't know a
life without rap you're absolutely right
I don't know nothing about us I mean I'm
income I mean god I could tell you a
million times I've rode in the cable my
car
excuse me rode with my kids in the car
and you know some come on the radio and
they you know they jibbing and jabbin
but that's something you know something
from our era
then I'm like man that ain't that ain't
such a such that such a such that I
tried out daddy I'm like you know what
you mean like I don't know like y'all
you know every every everything they
invented [ __ ] everything you know
insane which is cool I get it but you
know I'm glad you know I'm glad that I'm
glad I grew up when I grew up like I
said one foot in one foot out and then
as we grew you know as a rap group I
felt like we were lucky we were part of
what I think is one of the greatest eras
of rap if you're talking about that 88
to 92 era of hip-hop that was a khole
error you have some awesome groups
awesome artists that a lot of them still
doing that stuff to this day and if
they're not the music
holds up you look at people you look at
the groups in that era man it holds up
and that you know and that's you know
that's what's cool I mean you know we
still a hit man nothing until I hit
jumping around away about how it took a
while to catch on by 88 89 it was run
like once Run DMC man arrows in my eyes
never go off like a [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
yeah you talk about yeah but isn't that
isn't that but I guess you can probably
go back to all like a lot of different
music forms and be like you know I mean
like there was a time you know didn't
didn't with didn't the Beatles on Ed
Sullivan
set it off like there's always that bit
you know something said it all I was
gonna you know like Elvis Presley on Ed
Sullivan set it off
like you know nothing like this there
you know and it was those particles
hip-hop moments as well right I would
imagine are you you guys must have lived
through an especially you Chris what do
you think like starts an era and then
ends it like to talk about 88 to 92
that's that's only four years that's not
that long well this is what I'll say
I'll say well the reason why I kind of
used that those parameters is um 88 was
like if you go back I was like a huge
year like if you look at I was born at
the groups that release records that
year you're talking about some of the
seminal hip hop artists break it down
and and the groups that really establish
ID like oh my god you talk about
everybody from from us from kid and play
from NWA MC Hammer and and what I'm
saying it and my point is it started up
in a fresh print so it started reaching
weeks in Florida getting my lady
yeah I'm from like all that stuff was
coming out so weeks we reaching on we
reach in everybody you know what I mean
we reach in everybody and the only
reason why I clip it there oh my god is
the but after that it was that was the
that was the that was the gangster rap
era right which was which is very
important and which is you know though
those are my boys to gangsta rap started
in 93 94 I mean that's when they started
dominating you know I'm saying like this
one is that start dominating if you tell
my 88 to 92 you talk about crossover
artists like Mike ourselves kidding play
jazzy jeff and MC Hammer and Vanilla Ice
and down on salt and pepper and you know
I mean and on and which is important and
then you get we got every window we good
and then those are those are edible
phenomena you know I'm gonna look at
that community I think I'll acknowledge
I don't need all these oh my god know
what how much per 125 in each one yeah
just take a little bite oh just a little
piece of the tail then do not know but
that's it that's it you're gonna sleep
like a baby I'm on of this on the mic
I'm sorry but I'm saying yeah I'm you
know it does like different errors but
to me that 88 to 92 was so strong so
that so that gangster rap could flourish
no that's and that's what we was at
the country to you know mean the thing
about hip-hop that's so beautiful was
about rap music is so beautiful it
reflects exactly what's going on at the
[ __ ] time whatever it is you
know anything 88 the 92 ever anything
and people getting to know each other
and he ain't gonna hurt nobody and
parents you still don't understand and
then and then you know 92 93 it's like
hey man you know shit's [ __ ] up man
and we got riots and you know let you
know of people of color still getting
shot Chronicle music copies of the
original chronic was 92 I don't know if
this was a facialist or not but it's I
just typed in rap albums or hip hop
albums in 1988 first one is Public Enemy
they take the nation a million oh Jesus
quite an w8 Straight Outta Compton then
select regular great adventures of Slick
Rick Boogie Down Productions by all
means necessary I don't know if any of
these are classics
they're all they're all classic everyone
says I keep going I'm supposed to get to
kid and play to why we would be said
1982 that was the next one and then was
it no no I'm fine here I'm only alive
keep going cool autumn alter magnetic
mcs critical break beatdown cortical
beatdown EPMD strictly business tomorrow
Big Daddy Kane long live the king come
on eazy-e easy does it
come on biz markie going off picking
boogers come on Eric being my cam follow
the leader
come on are you kidding I'm all know 88
the Glen I was going on that's all hop
10 listen long time in 88 so I don't
know nothing about [ __ ] me taken I
was doing straight-up kind and I was
listening to the brothers inside in
those days what is it with a lifetime
but they be boxing was they doing they
were listening to the hot album was
Bobby Brown don't be group had just come
out and I still remember going into the
laundry room and they were playing
dominoes and they were cooking and when
that song came on what are they cooking
um what would take cook the brothers
nachos yeah there was one brother ecchi
he worked in the kitchen with me yeah
and because look up some nachos we would
go at lunch we had 20 minutes
Furlow everyday pretty much to walk to
the store get your [ __ ] and walk back
right so we get bags on that chillin
with my cheese and you take the thing on
the iron and you melt the cheese but you
would cut jalapenos actually onions
black olives so it was the real deal and
they buy shredded mozzarella and they go
down to the HIV unit and melted no maka
microwave we sell them for two but
nobody called mozzarella you're making
nachos he would he would dope him up and
she was a bad [ __ ] little skinny
dude then he had a partner
that was from Buffalo I forget t big t
six foot six
you know 320 captain diabetic rice don't
think about it and give a [ __ ] I don't
even think of I tried to cook ribs and
their [ __ ] like he was trying to do
revolutionary [ __ ] in prison but he
could never because you need too much
eating too much
well they too much attention what did he
get worse but they would make ham
sandwiches yeah but what it but I mean
the least I mean it was just everybody's
gonna know that yeah you know look at
that your boy was dropping knowledge
that's who everybody was listening to
prison Chuck D know the guy appeared
from Sam Oakland
there was a girl her name was really are
we talking about - sure - sure we really
drop it you know so it baby all letting
them go all they would others were crazy
ways I think I think life is wait can
you wait can you just go you what you
went to top 10 I did I might even need
to be someone's own thing yeah I can
Victor climbed up order some yeah just
yeah just do do do-do-do really because
like life is too short came out in 88 as
well like that's what that's what a year
was like that would that was a great top
10 don't get me wrong but that's when
short came out I mean it was it was a
time dude just educated me to my
broker's I didn't think about it like
that
no also 88 was 87 was there got me
prison that was huge there were two
albums does a black out with a white out
with the blackout windows by three crew
and I don't why family know what the
White Album was
welcome to the jungle all you talk about
gun control all you heard in prison that
was guns roses or for the love of a girl
named Frances what's the name again
who's saying that I just had a deer day
furtively for the limb of a girl named
Trent when that came on black people
would lose their minds in prison club
Nouveau oh my god
Club you I think you are doing shows
with that guy now shaking are you so
yeah yeah why you treat me so bad don't
remember sugar darlin brew money and
opened up a skylight with that but it
was not let me ask you a question
there's two rumors on YouTube des club
Nouveau rumors are the time that social
club rumors yeah the one my the the
original was
excuse me comic social club but it's the
same producer same guy Jay King now what
they've made it went back he went back
as Club Nouveau and did a and did the
rumors joint cuz sometimes what happens
is artists rerecord their own stuff to
try to get back control of it you know
what I mean there's like weird legal
stuff that goes along with it so
sometimes if you rerecord your own stuff
you did stuff you can do with it you
know I mean but time at Social Club was
original was original rumors but it was
the same saintly guy that went on to
create Club Nouveau that did Li know me
and all this neck so it's the same
entity same any Archer you release your
first time lady 888 though cassettes
before that sell them another trucker
now you know now we were like that like
no we wasn't non we wasn't now you know
now we were you know what we were lucky
we got yet we had got hooked up with
there was a guy from our neighborhood
that um was established producer a
Herbie Love Bug that had already created
the group salt and pepper
so he brought us behind so on pepper we
used to dance behind them and we used to
be in their videos and stuff and um you
know he got us he got us our record deal
and
so you know we try to come up with a
catchy name like originally our names
was kid cool out and playboys but we
shorten that to kid in play you know I
mean as you know kind of in the vein of
salt and pepper so you know we got you
know you got to be talented but you got
to be lucky and I think we were both you
know an engine shuts off the [ __ ]
record here everybody really loved the
Reverend everybody their life has
different crushes yeah you live your
life and you know if I could have had
right the big chick from Zone pepper
I would translate to Muslim be a little
mom so it's on my salt the big one the
big one I used to be big she's she swim
yeah yeah yeah you should be a thick
Jamaican she drove me crazy for years
that began requiring that well you know
what I'd say what I tell you what you
would eat well you know what we actually
get me to do um a television project
with some copper like in the next three
weeks well they have like the hip hop
kids and she's on it yeah she's a mother
one regret exactly right he was married
to Treach she was yeah well I don't know
if you ever married to son she had a
baby with church but yeah she's gonna be
out here in a few weeks so I would love
to introduce first of all that's Andy
that's Hep C that's my that's my
homegirl when we all hang out and we're
on tour together you know me and her
kick it you know I mean that's my
drinking partner that's you know that's
that's my fun love a DJ died no no no no
no this is other DJ DJ spinderella
especially beautiful tools and yeah the
little ones got a voice that's gold yes
the little one you could feel her warmth
on the microphone when she sings what a
man yes drives me crazy man butter
hasn't occurred I'm saying so you gotta
come up we got it we got we got shows
out here we're gonna do this this new
vh1 show with them so you know coming
here come out meet them you know I'm
saying they would love big take them
things they are raising troll myself
roses and they literally they'll control
you they know what's up man original
Cuban comes now no doubt but like I said
he's Jamaican so she knows she knows
what so she's you're making like like my
family so yeah but it's the cool thing
is like now you know we've been on
I love the 90s too like the last year
and a half and a lot of these dates are
with salt and pepper vanilla I robbed a
how big of these windows you know oh my
gosh yeah I mean what we sold out
Microsoft the last season with Microsoft
like 7,000 8,000 whatever I'm sure all
people my age and a little bit older
like early like late 20s early 30s 40s
50s men really thank I mean 8,000 in
austen 14,000 in Phoenix you know we go
we're going all over the place man
Missoula Montana South Dakota man we
just came from we just came from
Worcester Mass and Bangor Maine and that
was with kitten play Naughty by Nature
Montell Jordan Cisco Cisco was on that
show bizz Markie and Tone Loc was on
that show so yeah I mean you know first
of all you know that 90s is hot right
now for whatever reason and not just
with you know people I mean like young
people are into the 90s because they can
click back and looking I mean my kids
are just like they're fascinated with
that error and my son wants all my
clothes from the 90s and you don't
anything something about it so I mean
you know we kind of have to rock it and
meaning and pretty much the industry is
like you know who's ever alive you know
we'll pay you the door so they just I
just on the way here I switch between
the 80s aren't you know I have serious
in the car so you have the 80s 90s
studio 54 radio yeah CheY 45
lithium right and that was a back spin
with the other one houses boneyard I
just go from from from I got fire
stations the 90s covers everything the
90s gives me all kind of cut SWV yeah I
get those might those are my other
sisters they're very 80s today I heard
uh let me be the one expose out of Miami
you know you hear all this [ __ ] and
that's good stuff oh my god and tonight
we do those shows to those freestyle
shows like that south from the fever
does freestyle show so we'll let will be
on
Kida playa be on a bill with like judy
torres expose stevie be TKA come baby
come maybe we going done well that's
that you just it's just fun music man
this is like you know nobody was trippin
no just tryna get bit was way before
colors came no no colors came on 88
that's right yeah okay my baby
everything's right that's right it's
funny how I heard tonight that Saxon and
UFO one on a sample tour and they did so
well even without the guitar player
Michael Shanklin that they had a
reschedule a bunch of [ __ ] shows again
and that shows me there's a vacuum in
music there's a big [ __ ] vacuum in
music because of all he's banned to
getting together I mean the the the the
[ __ ] next tour summer thing went down
the tubes Led Zeppelin's not getting
back none that was the room right
through the millions they went back that
but how much money they must guy they
must have so much [ __ ] money
know your name they even said Isis would
give up their weapons I know is
epaulettes up for sec we ain't getting
back together dawg
they ain't got no money light resurrect
the devil wanna play like whoa yeah Rob
the plans like I got Jah is for several
castles general castles
these [ __ ] won't even break
down when I was total friend of money I
base it he called me and said how come
half this music and I write to it
like what are you looking for you look
of a definite but I can't find of 11 I
go broke I think what Zeppelin just went
on a year ago like they was they got so
much money they shut it down and they're
just like if you want if you wanna be
one us on iTunes you want us on Apple
music you want a song title like you got
a you got a pay man like you know me and
then I mean then and there already
you know they got castles man they got
councils and and look I used to hear
there was a guy um there was one dude on
in doors that would would [ __ ] [ __ ] up
because he would you know when they when
Cadillac and all these things want to
come
license issues for commercials and [ __ ]
you know to do there who had enough
money and he was like no he said Jim
wouldn't want us to do this and [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] down and so when you can't
get the doors what do you do you go get
that Led Zeppelin right back go they on
got a tour they don't got it - how much
do you got for that they got millions
for that so this is like man you don't
mean like when you get but that's -
means I mean but that's why I love
that's the power of music you know what
I mean and and not just them I mean
obviously those those bands are amazing
and incredible and it has been for a
long time but man you know listen you
know watch television or go online I
mean you know they like in music and in
particularly in terms of hip-hop I mean
they throwing that music up there all
the time and I mean I've got you know
I'm you know my our music has been part
of you know advertising campaigns man
it's it's cool it's cool to get paid 25
years or 20 years after you wrote some
[ __ ] that's cool but you know it almost
fits though that cycle you know these
you know these advertising executives
are like Lee's age you know what I mean
and that's the [ __ ] they grew up on and
they're just like eight when they're
thinking of these advertising campaigns
and these things like amen these are the
song songs they think of the songs that
they grew up with wrong no absolutely
and that's and that's what we wanted
like we were talking about how like that
really party like people they would go
and spend and I spent a night and get my
tickets to a concert
I'd like how big are these festivals now
Bonnaroo and all these music festivals
are huge I just Jamie was just that rock
on the range and I think Metallica
closed it out or was one of the main
Zion guard was supposed to be there
Friday wrong wise these I love the 90s
dates do they come and dressed with 90s
gear and the Hammer pants and Bing and
the Dookie rope chains and it's a thing
man like they they got you know I mean
all the girls from the office came ah
[ __ ] remember remember remember 92 he
was the [ __ ] [ __ ] let's go five six
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying was
like it's a thing it's a moranto but you
guys must know he's not he's not but he
should I mean I already doing it then
I mean he but he totally fits in that in
that realm I mean we just got back in
the days we did so many shows with him
puts on a great show you know he was
always a you know Mitch it was like
Ringling Brothers there's always the
moving and oh he does that like it was
dope it we both so it's great to have a
lot of people moving up on stage but
when you see the ability every week I
paying you're like god he got Sam is
that's why me me and play was like man
we go we gonna do we're gonna do this
we're gonna be like he would say we did
me and play we'd like the Simon and
Garfunkel a wrap
but you know what bro this idea who ever
put this thing like these together was
very smart how he did you guys started
in small venues you build momentum
listen the summer it has tons of work
for everybody that wants that show on
the 70s on CNN they had a show about
music in the seventh yeah it's still on
YouTube and [ __ ] in 1973 they did two
billion dollars or two million I think
was two billion dollars with the ticket
sales in this country but in 1973
everybody was on the run from oh yeah
that's what you got money I mean it but
I don't know it's always it's always
been that way it's always been that way
like that's that's how you get cuz you
know you got to wait around to get your
money from the record company and
they're gonna and they're gonna and
they're gonna fight you on it and
they're gonna battle you on it they're
gonna charge you back for a gang of [ __ ]
where you gonna get your money money
that you're gonna live and survive on
[ __ ] Road magic I get on the
road and so yeah I mean it was that way
back then and you know it's that way now
and to the point where you don't sure
you and your audience knows this that
that you know these record companies now
they do those 360 deals now because
record sales are so down that you know
the record company feels like they put
you out that well we we don't make a
record sales you know the way we used to
we give the music way so I want some of
your touring money I want some of your
merchandising money I want blank that's
why that's a 360 deal like I want
somewhere like what do you say like
Frank white like everyone I want I want
a piece right that's how the
dude that's how the [ __ ] works today
back in the days we do it like that the
record company was the record company
are touring money that was our money and
then we'll come back and fight you for
that you know later on but you know let
me actually is my brother so you
released your first time in 88 when did
the movie start knocking um like that
following year whose idea was house
party was you're right no no not at all
um the the writer/director
of house party was a cat named Reginald
Hudlin Reggie husband on his brother
Warrington husband was a producer and I
used to see Reggie Reggie was a video
director in the in the late 80s and I
used to see him out at the club's many
like a was all my thing was I'll do
whatever whatever
and he would step to me because he
wanted to she wanted to shoot some of
our early music videos cuz we you know
we were doing like you know kind of
quirky kind of cool-looking [ __ ] or
whatever but we had a guy you know we
had this white dude we used to use so
you know we would like I was like nah
man like no disrespect you know but you
know cool cool you know we got a guy
that we kind of vibe him with you know
whatever he's a guy that that that then
one time he's testing me says yo man I
got a movie script man I wrote a movie
and I think y'all you and play would be
great for it and blah blah blah I was
like I you know fast forward I get the
script you know back in those days it
was my job to read [ __ ] you know means
like play play and her you know her be
our producer manager like they never
went to college I mean not like that but
you know I'm saying I was considered a
brainiac cause it was like you know but
I can't read it you know tell us what
you know what it is you know you're
saying have you know everyone every crew
every crew they got a super power like
this is my bookie he reads this my
brother kills this is no slug of Steel
isn't clean I know it's the only thing
so my job was to read Darian so I read
the script and honestly I was like it
was it super power of reading so I read
it and I and I was like it wasn't all
the way there but i was like i said it i
said it's close enough that we can bring
it like it was a little corny but i was
like
I said we'll bring it there like I
thought maybe out of a hundred percent I
thought it was like 70% and I said I
said we can get it to 90 and if we get
it to 90 then you know we'll be all
right
so I told him I said that's it they say
well Sehwag with that thing you read I
said it was good I said I think we
should do it so they gave us like a
little um I don't know like a little
screen test or whatever me and play
whatever see if we had like chemistry
and [ __ ] so we you know we're in this
little small office you know New Line
Cinema wasn't wasn't [ __ ] back then they
was like one little goofy office on 14th
Street like down the block from Nels you
know like 14th and 8th you know I mean
they wasn't they wasn't [ __ ] they all
they had out at that time was Freddy
Krueger they had one Freddy Krueger
movie up and so they was starting to
bubble a little bit today thinking
internet anyway long story short they
want to do it but we still never
believed it until we like landed in Los
Angeles you know me before they'd be
like yeah whatever they got the [ __ ]
movie get out of here right it wasn't
the first movie who in the first house
party you got kid in play you got Tisha
Campbell you got AJ Johnson
you got Martin Lawrence you got full
force you got Robin Harris you got John
Witherspoon you know I mean we're very
Jerry Johnson AJ Johnson you know what
AJ Johnson is doing well there's - AJ
John - the little one right you talking
about that guy
yeah there was this - agent Johnson's
there's a female is a real pretty girl
that's right the dog the brown skin
where is she oh she's out here you know
what she did she got into the fitness
and wellness she world he is revenge Rob
Johnson bright things we should do the
main room coming once in a while I saw
one time I fell in love with a did John
Bryson 98 9/11 no no no bro she's she
got none she was in baby boy she was my
baby she was something a few think that
butBut she kind of she she got off the
thing like those but it into this whole
kind of you know wellness thing she's
been on a lot of these reality shows
like where she was she had to get
Lindsay Lohan she was like her life
coach you know she's into that life
coaching thing she's dope with that you
know you know teachers you know teacher
camera come on she's got everything my
wife and kids Martin
blah blah blah um yeah Mandy I mean
Robin [ __ ] Harris right and one
of my mentors love them with all my
heart never got to meet them look I say
can I take can I tell you everything I
tell Robin Harris to hit me i'ma tell
you I'm having stuff all right
I mean sit this anyway so you know we do
you know we um you know the first house
party you know I'm saying you know he
plays my father so you know we know you
know how it goes on movie sets you know
you spend a lot of time with each other
you know mostly not doing filming or
whatever you know so just talking so he
wanted to tell me a story one time so he
said man we tell you the story man I'm
trying to I'm trying to talk to this
girl man she won't invite me over the
house for dinner you know meet her
parents so you know I'm all nervous and
[ __ ] so you know I go over there and you
know I'm gonna press the parents so you
know I'm on my best behavior you know do
the right thing whatever like that
everything's going well it had a nice
dinner and then then then then the
mother came out brought out some dessert
they had some pie and they had you know
had some time and then we got to the
point where there was the last piece of
pie and last piece of pie for the father
told Robin II say man gone man i'ma go
and get that get that last slice of pie
and Robin said he said no no no sir I'm
fine I had enough thank you thank you so
much monkeys it man Robin get a piece of
pie man would you get that piece apart
mama done cook the pie you here with my
daughter here we had a great dinner man
had that pizza party no sir I'm good
what would you eat that pizza price
you're gonna eat that pizza pie all
right this delicious pie lien has
perhaps more passive power that last
piece of pie and finally problems like
okay all right so thank you all right
all right
I'll have that last piece of pie so he
eat the last piece of pie then down on
the line down the line um they washing
the dishes mother mother father in the
kitchen washing the dishes and Robin got
to go to the bathroom but you got to go
to the bathroom you got to go past the
kitchen to go to the bathroom so as
Robin going to the bathroom goes past
the kitchen
but the parents are and then you hear
the father say can you believe that
[ __ ] ate the last piece of pie [ __ ]
Robert Harris man was so good
can you believe that [ __ ] the last
piece of the last three or four times
all right thing is Berlin you [ __ ]
bag me I stayed up and watch it cuz a
Robin Harris got a little scene under
the [ __ ] umbrella know when he's with
the other two black dudes yeah kiss sure
kills me with the Jamaican dude killed
goofily sweet dick Willie and all that
[ __ ] ain't believing all right and let
me tell you he and guess what just
kickin it with him as a person he's as
cool as you thought it was like he used
to you know I mean he so he was so doped
like you know it's on that movie house
party like it was so like rugged right
like we would literally get like
paychecks you know like every other week
like you get a paycheck so I would get I
got a paycheck he got a paycheck and he
said he wanted to take me to cash our
paychecks but he took me one to take me
to the bank where he used to be a
security guard okay just show him like
eight months [ __ ] this my book so yeah
I'm covered a date with kids you a caddy
but [ __ ] guess who checked in I'm
saying he drive a 5.0 and he had a
pistol under the seat all day at all
times
and he would talk [ __ ] to the cops of
cops you know me at the light coming so
I shut up I'm like he talk [ __ ] to him
and he was older than us like he had
like you know he probably had like 10 15
years on most of us talk about me
playing Martin Tommy Davidson Tommy for
Joe Torre Ricky Harris or you know all
these guys using that same thing so we
all looked up to him and I tell you one
time we just play basketball together -
one time we were playing ball somewhere
in Burbank and you know we got into with
some you know some other crews man you
know some white dudes thought they was
all this and that or whatever and Robin
he stepped out boy he went out he went
he went to the car and came back and
came back with that pistol
which you know Jen shorts on and all
that man he had the touchdown they said
I was not which I'll talk about and you
know then they started on homina homina
homina high knees I get [ __ ]
that's what I thought and then you
nothing like he was he's that guy man he
looked out for us like he taught us a
lot you know he didn't you know
sugarcoat nothing I mean but he was a
good dude man like what like I said
cargo right yeah exactly sure car yeah
not me and he came out to let you know
I'm saying like he was a high school in
LA but he you know he had them Chicago
in Chicago okay like I said you know he
and I you he and I were talking because
we spent a lot of time you know I may
need to talk about it you know his wife
was you know his kids whatever like that
and and and he was and you know what
else he would do to he would fall asleep
at the drop of a dime
I agree so think he was like narcoleptic
cuz like he would fall asleep like he
would fall asleep like in between takes
like you doing right now no falling
asleep and looking at each other's eyes
party one yes after that you blew up
already brother yeah yeah that was a big
deal and then you wasn't how quickly to
the house party to like real quick like
real quick yeah like yeah like real
quick and and the product and the thing
was I mean for that might look it may
look everybody benefited you know I'm
saying um but they um they didn't have
an option on us beyond that first movie
so the first movie they got it's like
really cheap the second one that's when
we stuck them up you know comparatively
you know I mean um and yeah it was hot
you know I'm saying you know I go you
know the first one hot I party hotter
you got to I was 42 you know and then
you know then do a house party three and
then do a class act
so you know that was a that was a hot
that was hot little movie run right
there you know but you know I mean and
and I mean i think i think i hope that's
why the film still hold up because maybe
we just having a lot of fun and a lot of
good people know you could tell yeah I
mean I'm Joe and you didn't do better
there you've been on a gang of movie
you know when [ __ ] having fun
when they ain't right and you know when
you gotta when it's not a fun situation
you know like I well I got a I got a
summon something else because that
energy ain't here other times you like
oh these [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] are jamming ain't gonna be
no thing to get to where I need to get
to that's what it was with us suppose
it's like oh man is I mean you know it
ain't like we making Citizen Kane you
know we doing house party movies but you
know people come to depend like a man
our party movie gotta be some we gotta
Adam sometime we need some dancing we
need some you know we need some pretty
girls and woollen and whatever whatever
and kiddin play is gonna go through some
[ __ ] you know like like you know like
like homeboys do you know that's a lot
of thing to this day so many people come
up you know either both of us or
individually and they're like man I said
man you know I had a homeboy in high
school and they said they used to call
us kid and play you should like me tight
and that's that's what that's what it's
become you know I mean I'm also they
said like I'm an old don't try to don't
try to get in between them don't try to
separate them dudes I'm [ __ ]
tight like kiddin play like that's what
it's come to represent you know I mean
like multiple to stick together whatever
you know up down whatever whatever but
nah man how you gonna get between you
can't get between kid and blade we're
gonna get between you next week peanut
butter and jelly huh
I don't think so okay I got another
funny story - oh look oh look at this
you can go down to halftime here
okay ass holy brother brother hit it I
got some for you don't but Tony Bennett
this have time in Messiah I'm gonna free
some a beautiful soul I'm a freestyler
this man need to change in the free
stuff I wanna be around to pick up the
pieces really swing songs or what them
yo that's all away and I'm sorry doc a
3:06 my crew my body movin in on last
time we ate five two hundred you gotta
be able to get a wh a double my night
for more of they weaken what's the
problem
Dubi Dubi go public with you you only
get three of them that's it don't be
don't make me climb on top of the
chocolate and the who cares who people
in that misery loves company wait and
see
I mean I wanna be around you like
macking coke to see how he does it I
like the platter
Wallace like this flawless vocal let him
like so much this is so clever
let's go so far
what's going on with those stairs over
there anyone stable we see how you bet
that no I'm saving you let's go training
tonight let's go we're training we spent
that don't respawn degree five more
double tap this thing oh [ __ ]
as I'm talking about you bad
[ __ ] always turn up to the end
let me get some shoutouts man Acosta who
loves you
my main man lon Rosen cut I got you
trapper welcome Uncle Tony
J'son Cleo my man burger the Armenian
mob bro Lingus Amanda Guthrie and my
main man calm man
don't forget Icehouse working out with
uncle Joey
Thursday night ten bucks you know Donna
you have some chicken wings
you got a beer and you go to [ __ ] home
how's the wing kick open going to
delicious your kick off the [ __ ]
Memorial Day weekend with uncle Joey I
got a list I go up there we talked about
it and everybody goes home happy we all
learned something understand me the
other two so now it's 1995 our number
another get down sounds of the [ __ ]
drunk anyway wait before I forget I want
I want to have you look this up and then
and then we'll come back to yes it's
something Adam that I've been thinking
about but I'm working on I'm kind of
working it into into my stand-up but top
100 duo's and and I saw kitten play came
in on that list but I was a little
perturbed at what number we came in on
like 50 best I'm rolling stone is that
going like the huns like top 100 duels
digital uh maybe this one mmm Digital
dream no no not even music duo
the top duels not even music goals like
partying clang yeah I like I like like
peanut butter and jelly is the you were
you know there was kidding boy like
Batman yeah yeah that's [ __ ] History
sport it is but but I'm but I was still
like you know I you know I was flattered
and then I was like wait a minute
they're head of us like peanut butter
and jelly I didn't have a problem with
but it was like a couple of other ones I
was like in today's world
well everybody bitching usually
accomplishments you young black
[ __ ] man do you have any idea
of the accomplishments I always say
under the circumstances and how he's
uses an example no offense
when you look at the cover dr. Dre's
chronic that picture him yeah on that
day he could have been president United
States on that day look at his [ __ ]
face when you guys were doing you
started some [ __ ] listen listen dog
gods nobody know what the [ __ ] you were
doing now nobody know what the [ __ ] we
didn't really ate we didn't know were
sitting back now thinking of my life in
those days and I was still stuck in the
early eighties I was still crossing over
there was some of the [ __ ] I liked and
somehow like late I liked white lines
yeah I like that you know how much [ __ ]
yeah I like all those but but expose
type [ __ ] I suppose example of the girls
that was fun expose was [ __ ] radio
[ __ ] I'm talking about them look at you
[ __ ] are doing early on when I
was going over the cop with it let's get
it get it together let's get it get it
again a lot real lows a lot of me will
along with those stars that's an orphan
I have four stars that's okay that's
[ __ ] that's 500 Lee are you [ __ ]
kidding me time you got to do two grand
tonight Luis Gomez is coming on
Wednesday he's looking for blood he's
saying that [ __ ] you may be happening
it's not as a week we'll be [ __ ] you
need two thousand seven nights we use
last night I'm doing a front seven night
you need my services
stop your crying
jeez tonight it's over what the [ __ ] you
think we're talking about right right
they were that ready
letting come up you're telling me I will
die I saw a little bunch is coming on
you're gonna do 2500 I am when is that
you got me at least 2,200 tonight you're
gonna piss jello different ah we die
either way
we'll get a feelin I'm still nibbling
man you're gonna piss gelatin this week
for the persons I'm already pretty I can
barely present it in what was we gonna
go see a doctor them but yet EP stars
dog stop stop talking to sell stories
you're cutting yourself short
big another little nip yeah just don't
worry about nothing keep nibbling yeah
but there was one list that I saw like
top 100 duo's or whatever likes you
compared to Simon and [ __ ] Garfinkel
yeah yeah they were way they are I can
do it was worth it we were like we were
like number 70 snap here's your [ __ ] you
know how you are restored you let
another 77 yeah but but you don't mean
the competitor in me was just like
really what number would you want to be
though I don't know even say not tell me
I don't know top sweaty all right all
right but you know what you're right
when you think about it just like you
know like I said this is the same list
that peanut butter and jelly like if I'm
on the same list as peanut butter and
jelly then that's probably pretty good
you know what I'm saying
so what else is on there the best was
like what uh oh I I don't see this one I
top topped 100 foot in top 100 dual
that's what I did
you did and what and what came up how
then was I that high did I do the
imagines on me okay here we go
Tom and Jerry bad man Rob there we go
han Solo Chewbacca
yeah Bert and Ernie so a scooby-doo and
Shaggy Jesus Christ look Scooby always
above milk and cookie don't believe that
milk it I'm saying this with mooking
laughing I don't think this is like uh
like a official this is like people can
vote on it with numbers kitten play
let's find it Oh hamburgers and fries is
on it good this is a good list to be on
Frank I'm telling you I know I saw it I
was like I know where there's somewhere
Oh
here I think we might need to get the
church people to get on out seeing you
I'm gonna get you back on energy well
that's right Lucy and Desi gotta be it
was up and then one of them list we was
like number 77 or Egypt but everybody
you know our okay back up there yeah it
to come Richard oh yeah yeah hello yeah
tell the audience look out look out for
that vote vote for you boy
what were you studying for when all this
[ __ ] will came at you what were you
looking to do I mean just who you went
to this high school Bronx yeah what will
the science right I know you had a get
picked to go in there and you had to
take a test you know you know there was
um back back then if you wanted to go to
one of the specialized public high
schools there was three of them who's
five percent Bronx Science and Brooklyn
Tech so you have to take a test and
depending on how you did on the test the
the top kids went to Stuyvesant then
those bunk science and in Brooklyn Tech
was the number three was number three so
um so I made it to Bronx Science and I
mean thing it was you know I graduated
from there but then I went to I went to
college right down the block at Lehman
College and I was I was an English
literature major and at the same time
you know trying to you know kind of do
our thing you know we did a lot of
things man like before we ended up you
know as kid and play we were doing like
a lot of things you know you know and
then we then we just kind of figured it
out like I man it's gonna be the two of
us you know and and like everybody knew
what their job was you know like play
play has a great artistic eye and you
know so I so how we look and how we're
fashioned and what the album covers look
like an all at artwork [ __ ] and all that
you do that because I don't know nothing
about that what I do is I write the
songs that's what I do so you know that
that made us a good team and then you
got it you know you still gotta trust
one another and then like I said we had
the homeboy that had produced so i'm
peppering him already and he was hot so
the timing was right you know
and then you know the the movies get you
here they get you there you know I mean
like then after that it's like then
sometimes it's it's it's sometimes it's
a little tough because you not you're
not that same hungry cat no more you
know I mean you like you know we out
here you out here in Cali and you know
we smashing and you know we getting
Superman high and you know feeling
yourself or whatever you know so it you
know it we always had to almost kind of
shock ourselves back into that that
animal we used to be you know me because
it's hard man cuz you know we start
doing good you know what did I heard him
I heard Denzel say this from when he was
on on the award circuit he said 'yes is
a greater threat to progress than
hardship he said 'yes is a greater
threat when you get in which it gets
easy what you do you get soft when we're
up against it when it's hard moving I
know options what did you do we figure
that [ __ ] out we do it you know somebody
you know somebody lets you slide on some
[ __ ] man that's when we you know that's
when we ease up ease is a greater threat
to progress then hardship lonely ask you
something another I mean you start
telling you leave rapping live shows the
whole thing you probably did a little
bit demo when did you make when did you
decide when damnit get on the phone cuz
I met you in 99 baby at the end probably
yeah well Pablo I was gonna ask you when
to the everything Pablo we know whatever
cuz of Pablo Frances no but you with the
manager that's how we met he was without
worthy worthy you were worthy I'm
struggling to worry you came by and
asked me if I knew you I said no we
should and gave out ask me about my
accident we started talking oh but we
were I think we want it but I thought
yeah I was with him but it was it was on
a I don't mean you just do a lot of
Pablo show a lot of [ __ ] with Pablo yeah
I didn't CD in Houston
yes don't love them I love that book I
love it don't see him enough
and when when does anyone see Pablo a
Groupon mentor or you get this warm
feeling you do but like when is it you
know in saying like why would you I
almost feel like like like you don't
thing like like you know I don't want to
be crazy no but it's weird like you
don't saying like do we know he's alive
you know everything but you don't say
like he's out there every day man he's
one of those guys are still travels 47
week so he's America's quarter horse
I mean knows it Rob's he does Charlotte
he does funny bones he's out there and
those guys you can't control their
[ __ ] animals will have no children no
and you know what the guy was you know
he was he was always great to me and he
taught me a lot but when I you know
that's when I first started when I first
started jumping up and trying to do it
and you know me didn't know what I was
doing so I learned a lot from him you I
remember used to that the old I remember
you and me at the old Brea improv the
old one that we used to [ __ ] rock and
just a little repeater yeah just trying
to learn how to how to do how to do this
how to do this thing yeah before they
move it to new fly [ __ ]
you know I'm boy from 95 guys 2005 yeah
I was on seven nights a week like my
life chains for 10 years yeah the first
time I took a week off is no longer she
hard got released which was 10 year 12
years ago this week was when I said okay
I did a movie now I'm not gonna go out
five nights a week no boy took another
two years to get off to blow I got out
of the store for a while to adjust my
mentality
I just hauled around town and now I'm
back at the store
you man can I ask you something go man
I'm and you not go way back with Paulie
and all this in that man but man I never
never liked the store and I and I never
and I never perform there but you know
me I respect guys that do but man I was
just like man I just
and the energy and you're just like for
it really action on this question cuz
were brothers old school is your dislike
for it because they don't give you spots
or from the first time he walked in
there you go you know what this place
ain't for me
ya know not that they didn't give me
spots like they would that you know I'm
saying that that wasn't an issue it was
it was at doing it and then trust me I
was I used to go there long before I
became a comment III I would go there
with your pal and Martin you know I mean
I you know I was I was the funny guy in
the crew you know just checking and
taking notes and you know saying that
kind of deal so man I was up in that
place for long long long time I mean you
know remember all the hot girls that my
focus to highlight you know saying like
you said worthy and them used to be up
in there and you know they were smashing
smashing them waitresses and all this
and that name we was cool with everybody
and and and as a social place it was
especially then where you know in the
90s it was in the night it was awesome I
went to the ER last night digit but
here's the deal I'm too old to go to
every night there's a bunch of young
cats yeah so I try to go up in Bride do
Brian my live shows on Saturday 7
o'clock mainly I live mine and then
Tuesday I call it like I worked out a
little bit but it'll work out no more so
that you gotta go down a little polish
material is Shakeel in switching between
Chappelle and find Joe Rogan this oh
that time I have to roll it up like oh
yeah cats a roll up like that during a
week just we show right so you can't
even go up in girls lose that if shows
out to the builders people never ring
listen to the part number dude used to
do his Fat Tuesday air boom god no yeah
that's all he's doing
reading the first time I did a Richard
Pryor road and then said that Missy
boxed up 35 hours he got me out of them
Monday night Latino night right and you
know what I used to do the black moon I
did great for like three times and then
I died at freaky Monday yeah at the end
product the improv
yeah I just slowed deck and I said no
more boy before because those those
death all score ei ting well the guy in
front of me said [ __ ] so he was white
and and who's know
Friday was a Chris talking Chris
practice I guess I'm on the [ __ ] off the
stage so now there was no none other
white dude essentially great I was the
host at night I would have brought up a
black dude right to say something about
what happened right bring me all right
I couldn't say I'll cleanse the palate I
think the digital Maci let me talk no
but those guys they against you to this
entertain the most you do like the catch
the D hosting though they were injected
st. not not just not thinking that they
want a train wreck they wanna they wanna
thing that's why that's what does reason
why I don't [ __ ] with that sometimes
either you don't saying like they're
gonna get your [ __ ] up intro they're
going they're gonna do 15-20 minutes in
front of you on some ratchet [ __ ] and
then enemy and then send them to bring
you up on a smooth to it like you don't
say like the return what do you woody so
yeah I mean look out of any club any
place you'd like to be like as a creator
for like what am i gaining what am i
gaining what am I getting what do I got
a duel to win here what I plan on saying
like and like you say it's like any club
like you going is like I'm an you know
what
thanks for me you don't think it ain't
for me I know this listen but I'm saying
I mean there's 10 clubs across the
country that I don't even walk into
because I get the same feelings as you
my brother right
you know Thank You kanima dude I love
the Laugh Factory
I love I love you know I'm saying you
know I love the improv on holiday no
problem with the California room I can't
why you dude I'm come on how many how
many how many how many boots not even
clubs how many converted bars have we
done how many Willie Barcena and Jeff
Garcia and Sebastian Cetina and Robert
Zapata and Rick Martinez shows that
we've done like like it ain't about you
know we've gotten up in time you know I
get up thank God get up in gully spot up
invalidates the pilot for Robertson
pilots eight years ago and every time I
see him he goes dog it's gonna be done
pretty soon yeah
I wouldn't want that [ __ ] now in the
everyone can we're gonna sell that to
now 810 years later we did all those no
no no listen bro I paid my dues just
like you we were there we were at the
same rooms of the Tuesday night I was
wrong yeah and a burrito and a taco I
used to be in those rooms with your [ __ ]
yeah some Casa latina [ __ ] the get up
will be bar seven role where they threw
a nice tortilla for two or three years
moment so that it changed a thousand
times the names people have no idea that
yeah man okay no yell I would switch it
up these one-nighters yeah it was
training guys in those days for me
because in those days he would do a
Willie Barcena room from 8:00 to 10:00
Rudy Moreno then Rudy retained us when
we had a nice house on last 10:30
it could be the brave bull - and there's
a hammer and then you would have an
11:45 at the Comedy Store which is gonna
be late because Eddie Griffin was going
to do three hours now but at least you
picked up 40 and 35 you made 75 hours I
put 20 in the gas tank right by Grandma
blow for 40 I owe you 20 you know I'm
saying that's why I can wake up and have
cigarettes and breakfast in the morning
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing -
enjoy bananas look here I got a budget a
budget legendary it was God look bro
those rooms I didn't listen when after
2007 all those little rooms shut down
for a while and bro I was starving and I
couldn't think around I'm not doing coke
but I'm broke how's it gonna go
oh I'm living on procedurals and
weekends you know what I listen those
weekly shows and it's allotted Monday
nights you go to Universal and the kid's
name Emma Jon Lovitz illness because
this was way before
hahaha he's like what the ha no no no no
universe one Monday night club is still
there I know what's the crazy guy used
to book that Ernie G Monday night my
little mama 40 bucks across them at the
anima you went there yes you went in
there you picked up 40 you shot the
Latino night The Laugh Factory
they paid you 25
check right yeah you gotta come back get
there yeah you gotta go back then I go
the Comedy Store get 10 minutes and go
the [ __ ] home and those that and then if
you're really cool in those days you did
a Monday night the improv if you were
white you went up before 10:00 to 9:00
yeah
so you white you got out of there by
10:00 tonight the first comment would do
six minutes six minutes and then it was
a - white dude spots and then they put
flavor in there and then they turn all
black so they would have like me Josh
wolf Dave Attell would sprinkle that
room with machine guns and then a black
dude will go up there and rip that
[ __ ] room apart then from there
wait were you doing it when I remember
my man um I used to call him - zooming I
was there with zoom zoom a woman when a
here's a running then he ran it before
if he did it before DeRay right Oh way
before you go dear a this is 97 yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah do man who has to
Laurie Corey Miller great kid I send
them my love yeah there's so many those
I'm telling joy beers yeah yeah yeah we
love them I love that dude with all my
art I don't yet then I used to go to the
Laugh Factory and do a Tina knife or a
Gilbert Esquivel and then from there I
go to the comedy store but if he that's
how you rocked on Monday night how to
have a triple header you had to do the
store right the last Factory and the
[ __ ] right but then somebody had up
somebody had a bar gone somebody has
yeah you have any work bar Santa had a
had a you know I'm saying ladies and
gentlemen with Martinez people always
talk about in Moreno I had to leave my
way because I couldn't find work and let
me tell you something guys I was doing
if I do the math now I can't tell you
I was copping $60 a night in cocaine
four to five nights a week and my wife
had no idea because alright cuz the
money never came up missing I was
picking up twenties fifties seventy-five
eighty twos what's-his-name would pay
you fifty seven but you always picked up
eighty bucks at night all Soviet what's
in that bottle over there
tequila let's go eighty bucks a night is
[ __ ]
400 bucks yeah and let's protect me
thank you
life sir is half of that like the
colonies no pays you 15 I'm low fee
people know that when I go to come this
on a Tuesday night on a Wednesday even
back in 90 [ __ ] seven they pay you $15
in those days the a MacLeod will pay you
twenty seven seventeen fifty if it
presents how long the [ __ ] spot was
and and last factory paid 25 bucks on
Monday night but they may they paid you
with a check a month later you be
sitting there but I checked to win a
math going yeah did three Latino might
some people over 75 bucks right and
you're gonna have 125 so this you had to
make a living doing one-nighters and
then was on abundance of and every once
in a while you pick up one for 300 yards
oh [ __ ] yeah somebody did like baker's
me a little opera thing or no no no you
drop one of those you but I tell these
guys oh I picked up one when you don't
dissemble my month alright maybe really
rock in this town I always come true in
December there's a god up there that
goes you know what Joey you suffered all
year but the Sun right was right
the thing yawn style one year I booked a
non-union commercial 20 years ago
walking in for another audition and they
gave me like $3,000 cash four days
before Christmas today a shooter today's
shoot international buyer blew up with
that year now but when you first get
here and you're doing $15 spots are you
fighting your bump in cigarettes at the
store so you can borrow $20 from
something at 20 and gonna find out and
those days I could steal cigarettes from
the gas station across the street right
there waffle in alcohol you know I'm
thinking about I'm thinking don't know
we can think of the laugh act it was
down up know which way down it was by
the guitar so that now it's a tire shop
from 97 to about 99
Neri morning I would wait for the owner
to walk out and pump gas and I'd walk in
there and put my hand behind the counter
and took how many cups over there there
we have cups over there right powernet
right next to the fridge on the other
side oh sorry
yeah what are you drinking out of the
bottle yeah yeah yeah if you don't mind
Adam none I don't drink that [ __ ] that's
somebody left out here so I think she
had the hurt but don't worry about
tequila kills everything I'm Boyd
teasing is over like that episode of Law
& Order bang bang yeah no no it was a
different [ __ ] so those those gang
those okay something like those what
those bro those are the hustle did show
the hustle days bro yeah those mixed
with the Comedy Store are you kidding me
that's like being a fighter yeah you
know what it but I'm doing four [ __ ]
training sections right so it's not that
I don't respect that they don't respect
the Comedy Store like I know what that
place means like I mean I know that
place in the annals of comedy but man
you know it doesn't work for you doesn't
work listen rich he sure was walking
past the main room one night and when
she looked in the door and she saw the
president show this was way before miss
you buddy she had to pass you and she
looked up on stage and rumor was that
she waited for me to go off and because
I'm making the Arirang on calling for
spots and next week Rudy goes I'm a
regular Joe what do you think I go come
on down Rudy we get the spot on a
Wednesday night his spotters at 9:45
who he shows up at 9:30 and there's five
guys waiting to go on before we're
running late because if I'm writing I
came innocently sitting there for 15
minutes and going I never come back here
again and in the back of my mind I was
used to it that I can have become a part
of who I was I would go down there to
socialize so whatever my spot came up
yeah he's already for what else
sometimes I knew I wasn't going up know
if I call Mooney show up with yeah it'll
do you might as well go dice was there I
saw Paul moon dead go home yeah joe
rogan a take a boy in those days Rogen
was doing 40 but any Griffin was doing
college Mencia
I mean college was doing too much come
on
he was doing it when every no more man
it might go home I do just me I said but
I don't when I beat him up folks I'm
like yo I'm out I'm out I'm out funny
how Dave Chappelle started a trend to do
a long sets be case only 99 2000 and he
bristled onstage at 10 o'clock at night
and he would get off in five to two I
mean can you imagine actually you and
your girlfriend Paula on the side of you
call me you boys here on punches and you
fly [ __ ] down there and you park your
car when you walk in there and it's not
Ron Funches
it's [ __ ] that he grip at ten o'clock
at midnight Eddie still on stage now
listen I'm a look in the eye Li and tell
you something at that day and age I
understood it I understood what he go
was I understood all those things so I
didn't take it as personal as a lot of
other comics pull up we're taking it no
but that bad but it's [ __ ] ain't right
no no no it wasn't not right [ __ ] ain't
right and I know you remember this how
and who's a mentor of mine and an idol
of mine as well of Paul Mooney but I
remember when Paul Mooney would come in
there on the late night test and his
mission was to drive every white person
out of the showroom like summarily you
know I mean like that was his you know
what I mean he was like some like he
came and he was on that tip like and he
will work on each one he would get up to
that you know all right you know they
they just hit him with he would you
don't mean sometimes that was his goal
like I'm gonna drive each and every
white person from here with my voice and
thought guess we used to have to follow
him for a year well mornings you're
looking at I learn more good you go to
no I mean I would always go down there
that would be the man now lady Paul
Mooney and Joe Zia's I would sit back
there and I would be started the set
would be excuse me 20 minutes late and
I'd sit there going you know first I got
nothing to do tomorrow in those days I
got up at 8 in the morning anyway I
would slept till 5:00 to sleep the way
I'm just tip-top when I was a marine oh
yeah
amazing but I would follow him I still
got the lineups for a year she put me
behind and I learned and one night that
is trial by fire
I kept hours in the club in Miami will
you bring home we done I think home we
would do great and finally they booked
up all they got in Miami Tampa this was
in Coconut Grove yeah I know the one I'm
not one 2001 oh that one
yeah but the Marino's and oh yeah and
thousands of 2001 yeah I get lovely in
there my feature phone and he's having a
rough week it's the week that the Cubans
sent the government to go get LEM finish
so he kept going up on stage like just
he started ripping the Cubans problem
right off the bat I'm howling in the
back but those Cubans they were not
eating right nothing this kind of waste
going you're Cuba's got you to make a
wake-up call yeah yeah walking around
because I cherish it
you [ __ ] I can make a wake-up
call mañana talking all this nonsense
and [ __ ]
they came in here and took Kelly on and
that's what used to go Madonna I knew
where she was manana he would go off on
that [ __ ] and he would go I mean it was
just a different way of looking at it he
had a hard time like Tuesday and
Wednesday but by Thursday he picked it
up he picked it up he picked up a way to
attack the Cubans right and then get him
back and make it funny I don't know was
that after that yeah yeah oh he had just
about them like these women on top of
each other like yeah each other for rats
oh yeah Mel what up you don't say you
got to find a way to do it like you just
say little things to me bro that really
I learned yeah like I would ask him
stupid [ __ ] please give me a really
answer and then he started talking to me
and he would talk to me about horses and
[ __ ]
horses Texas he was again we like what
small like all horse it like that yeah
yeah yeah you know that's why I've never
been to the Kentucky Derby know you yeah
man I've been there like three times
leave another piece out story you'll see
the Kentucky Derby sake no see where it
goes or in the daytime
I got things on my bucket list if you if
you like a horse dude you got to do it
you know they got these you know they do
it's like several years ago but there
was organization they were trying to get
like more celebrities of color at the at
the Derby so man they set it out first
man they flew us there put us up you
know I mean like take this off and
whatever man we went and you know you
get all you know you get all forgetting
you know dressed up you know your lady
my lady's there with a [ __ ] hat and
[ __ ] and mint juleps and [ __ ] and
something to see and then like in the
infield
that's like Waldo white-trash cat's got
you know he's like I like I like a
NASCAR race or whatever that's in there
but that's not what we are they had us
in like a you know like a like a box and
whatever [ __ ] is dope give me the guys
ever be here like once again humans that
yeah nitrous cars with its fresh you're
gonna run what the [ __ ] what is rice
comes up hey yo let's y'all got rules a
week we need a mute we need music we're
here then I can I can take of our
imaginary can I read where the stars
here what's going on there's no music
there's no music if there's no music
Toby and my brother
we just chitchat maybe you know we we
need like a we need like a with me a lot
of we need an instrumental hip-hop beat
that our senses directly I can freestyle
super goodness police take it
you know go ahead to the police beggarly
please as I child oh you're a bottom
before also then we must come on the
show
rap you know what the words gain out
know that you I got 1,500 2,000
milligrams the word gain out there we go
rap to that like Ohio play the spot and
stick the whole thing is you know if you
do if another together I'm gonna take it
down in YouTube and you can also a soul
dude you can't be single no [ __ ]
music here the same well even twerk me
just amuse you can't even do music that
that I that I'm making up out of my head
no no no music yeah but you know what
you got to do they got these things on
like these cats take karate they product
these music they put up these CDs of
just of just beat and you they give you
permission to use the beats any way that
you want to I'm gonna put you up on it
are you I use them all the time I made I
make records with them that I've sold
and they say Amen and it says like when
you like to what you rule by the CD and
we say hey man you know there's like 20
beats here and they're like yo these
beat usually beats anyway you want we
don't care we do the right wah wah so
I'm gonna put you up on that I leave
something like that what you can hear
that we can do whatever you know stars
none of you are you wait what commit to
250 x4 you might got something to do
later what are you guys gonna do you got
some to do late I live is stare at the
wall some of y'all like you didn't break
a thousand milligrams from the delay
from the door later 250 and two is 450
and three stars four stars four stars
whoopty-doo 300 is 800 working way off
your $1200 the minimum and you're
slipping I'm gonna do one more i'ma do
one more head just one even even even
[ __ ] is my name here take my chances
even [ __ ] as kid is taking you can kids
taken to you
eat the [ __ ] dude I'm gonna with
you're gonna ready yeah at least you
going into the cave knowing you know
saying go why you know not knowing you
got um no ezel I um that El Rey Network
you know what's that I watch Friday
night sometimes they have a kung fu
movie yeah that's what I'm talking about
like I'm late like on Sundays like all
day learn anything you have sighs
married or like all them just do is to
[ __ ] with it I like I'm like I got a big
bag of weed and a little Bruce Lee
Thursday would ya man we took my Green
Hornet decision Green Hornet you
remember that yeah Kato remember kid oh
yeah he disappeared for a while they
came back with yes mr. fury
mr. fury Chinese connection but um the
Chinese flag returned returned Dragon
Enter the Dragon it was all over Chinese
collection Chinese connection was you no
no no no dogs and Chinese allowed and he
[ __ ] unbelievable kick the sign and
no man kill me
Bruce Lee was the mother come on man
Bruce Lee :
he's gonna throw but I tell you what as
though busy was man we like that next
era you know with those you know what
there was was wu-tang kind of films man
we like that better
no not me I did I was traditional when
he died because not because well when he
brought I watch he when he died maybe it
was about eight months I watched
colorful movies I didn't want to say
started flying through the air I was
done man you crazy telephone man oh no
that's when we really got into it
because if you look at it look who she
was dope
even saying he was a bad girl tradition
number they own the boat and enter the
Dragons and white guys do I bother yeah
yeah you're doing there and really make
I gonna [ __ ] around he's like don'twe
shots out like Bruce Lee was dope but
trust me when you got to like you know
five deadly venoms and master killer and
all that whoo tang and 36 chamber and
all that man I really like those
movement I want to see one of those cuz
they
and all that I got all the pointy
hoagies Rama this was the [ __ ] Lee I go
to Jersey City to watch one of those
[ __ ] movies by this time I had the
time fully from kung-fu movies and I
don't remember which one it was
I get the bus I get off week I mean ten
minutes into a movie they chasing a
Chinese guy and I loved it I was in and
all sudden he's running with this thing
that must weigh 300 pounds - treasure
chest okay I've been there I packed up a
safe one time and ran out of a [ __ ]
place wasn't no [ __ ] yard engine
running but I carried it for a few feet
Adrenaline's a [ __ ] he wasn't he
wasn't Bob Hayes it gets to a [ __ ]
mountain that chaser he looks up at the
mountain Lee and he goes like this with
his safe he throws it up into the air
and then he jumps lands on the mountain
grabs the gold out of the year I gotta
put my popcorn down and that was the end
of my kung-fu theater you know how sad
was that see let me tell you something
that's how sad it was I tell you what I
made a comeback when I got arrested when
I got when I got when the court got
released for me November 18 1987 against
my best judgment my buddy had to do from
Detroit that was great he goes go home
lately I didn't go home I told was on at
all I didn't tell nobody where I was
going I rented above the law Lethal
Weapon was out and people would see that
[ __ ] I wouldn't watch that [ __ ] and that
was the first time I watched some
martial arts fellow was above the law
anybody seen Richie no that was the one
before that newsroom there anybody
Richie Bobby Lupo anybody see what you
did to Bobby Lupo was Bobby Lupo who
Shaba that's the one when he's a Richie
the Chinese guys fixes in it but that
was the first but beautiful oh no no I'm
lying to you come to Salix with Chuck
Norris 83 with Dennis Farina garbage men
table under the table that was one of us
would've know one of his first movies
Dennis Farina got old money no Dennis
really got midnight remember Midnight
Run
seven but before that Dennis Farina
showed up in code of silence and there
was Oh thief 81 he was one of the
[ __ ] bad guys check it out Lisa at
IMDb dennis farina see this press film
was it was a Chicago movie it was either
like the first Dennis Farina wait wait
you know what so come on before wait
let's go back because I wasn't actor you
don't write that show from Chicago
let me see with my Andrew Dice Clay did
that but then he did um he did on one or
two later season it but so I was gonna
answer like somebody like that like yeah
I need something like that uh three was
his first movie what the [ __ ] you think
you're doing what's the second movie -
on TV movies rumors
what was the second phone what is the
code of silence coldest who the [ __ ]
know you think I'm a [ __ ] I'm a
Taurus Johnny your expert and instead he
came back with Vince I was 87 which to
me
the best commercial mobster ever the
[ __ ] in the film I've said it once I
said a thousand times
Rick Ramos better than Rob De Niro and
analyze this better than Robert De Niro
until you see Robert De Niro and [ __ ]
Goodfellas you know [ __ ] like that but
we were talking about this before like
you actively yes I was act
I was asking something like like was
like wow how nice no never
sometimes interviewer get interviewed
later the first time I did analyze that
mice I thought I kept saying your scene
might be with the little they have not
decided yet
okay and then a week before the ice shop
they said no no no your scenes with
Anthony one puggly I go perfect but so
when I was there I was there for two
days but they had two cameras going in a
and B was it out here no Jersey side
soprano neighborhood right there in the
cut right in the [ __ ] covers and
Kearney and all that [ __ ] right there
Oh sign right there on the streets they
had the trailers ax and they said the
vero shooting
reducing overall the other thing so
really I never really I got to see him
like you know ten feet away that I take
a picture of break his balls not even
close I didn't say we wouldn't have that
I would never do so I wouldn't do that I
wouldn't get my day alert and then I
booked a boxing movie and I read the
script and I was going to play his thing
and I learned my lines I ain't paying an
acting coach I made notes I'd tape
myself and I was prepared my scene was
Thursday night and it was a 15 minute
scene but they wanted me to come in
Thursday morning I said you know what
how about that flying I got a [ __ ] to
run this deal on a ticket I use my miles
how about I got a red Wednesday right
they go come on down right I fly down
there I get a room I check it you know
me I'm look around everything's kosher
rolling joint I'm gonna be down there
for six or seven days I got a big bag of
[ __ ] weed with me I roll a joint and
they say when you check-in that you get
three meals cooked for you you have to
come on to the show from 7:00 to 9:00
11:30 to 1 right and five to seven and
it's one meal like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
ok I go I says they did shallow me over
to the set it's the first set with him
and your buddy LL Cool J okay now I
don't know this right I just want I owe
you owe us bro let's go check this [ __ ]
out
my homeless a if I'm over my head this
[ __ ] and sniff it out let me
just sniff this [ __ ] have I always heard
that what's his name it was always on
set he didn't give a [ __ ] everyone in
this trailer cause he always wanted to
see in spider-man 2 I was never in my
[ __ ] trailer I wasn't a knight when
I'd smoke though that but I was always
on the set watching but just in case he
needed me whatever Jack Nicholson
somebody said he was always on a set
Jesus always on day someone look just
like that they like do you know that so
I get
first seen with him in Janeiro now in my
mind it was a sharp blade Calero's there
is that two white dudes alone he's got
the director talking to him right now
Cool J comes over to shake hands they
hug everything's solid you know what's
going on I'm over here in this whole
thing they go back upstairs
they set the cameras up they block it
block a few scenes but they come down
they each go to the respective corners
about 25 minutes later let's go guys
let's do this [ __ ] I'm sitting there
drinking now it's late already to go
uncle J has become a great little actor
40 years brother and very young hey
guess what yeah I know that dude I know
that you belonged I know you do he
worked he worked at it he already gets
letters all the time so yes so he's
getting his he's ready to he ready to
get busy too huh tell them who can
better get busy I would be ready in two
positions or be even much was yes all
right action whoa whoa roll cameras
action [ __ ] hell out Cool J and him
start to talk and I could see that when
LL Cool J looks at De Niro I could see
it in his eyes you lose it okay and also
you're like double cut and also I can
see how a good drink I'm sorry I'm not
easing I was starting from scratch but
you could see it hello Cool J's head
next take boom after a minute
boom rattled shook okay
same thing they rap they shoot the scene
everybody's happy everybody goes home
the next morning is a scene is me and De
Niro alone he comes in and ask me with
where the [ __ ] do this by being him
alone same thing but they still do doubt
right so that was me and him I'm sitting
I don't what to do dick bro right all I
got to do is sit like this laying back
like I'm watching TV and I'm reading the
newspaper and he asked me a question and
I [ __ ] answer
I got into Saturday de niro shows up
about 9:15 whatever they shoot another
[ __ ] they should be in about 11 o'clock
my lemon o'clock he comes over shakes my
hand introduced himself I say hello he
asked me if I'm Italian the Cuban Wow I
had a Cuban frame is loved are giving
you ba-ba-ba-ba right very light-hearted
you want to remove the [ __ ] like it like
el Robins Bob the neighbors wouldn't
[ __ ] with me I don't say nothing he
walks away he desired was back he goes
you want to rehearse a little bit yeah
let's do it
boom done second rehearsal boom done
[ __ ] people tells me to take a pause
here boom done let's do this boom done
you guys ready yeah let's do this
and the whole time I'm [ __ ] what I'm
doing I'm looking at this [ __ ]
I'll have the balls to look at this
[ __ ] I'm glancing at but I'm
listening I'm making believe I'm looking
at him but I can't look at this
[ __ ] guys so you gonna get you
kind of wait till the time to go to
really work and to get it okay I sort
right I ain't gonna waste this my
brother first rate something somewhere
else another constraint he all right
and all of a sudden time stops and you
see the guy in Cape Fear yet he
Godfather - he you see the priest with
McDonald's ex-husband when they escape
from the jail in Buffalo and they became
priests and you see the other one the
other way the other one he dollars Yemen
he the Raging Bull and Robert Duvall dog
Oh be hunter you see every movie he's
ever been in and whatever thought you
had in your mind
stutters but also they go cut and you're
like what
Diaz you missed your line you're like oh
[ __ ] that's how powerful his face is
he's like but he knows he must him oh he
goes he thought I Enzo knows yeah they
know Robert didn't even know they know
that people gonna choke on the handle
yeah during rehearsal we're just
chitchat
Leo know all those guys got to know them
they know they
first time they got to looking I know
and I'm just me yeah it's kind of the
second take again this time I kept it
together and sent it but after that I
made myself just stay around and talk to
him for a little while and I kept saying
you know the guys right so what you're
saying is you wish you would have you
put eyes on him before like got that
overweight would've mattered it was no
matter I was gonna go down I could have
gone to a dance with him and the first
and I thought man it's still gonna go
down and you're right Rob there's
certain people yogi uh somebody
mentioned to me once there's a scene
with Denzel in the movie and we were
talking on my son and he goes dog
there's nothing worse than Zell stand
down if you wanna lose you don't good
you just your whole body yourself yeah
he goes the first two times it's because
it's just hold on it's ten [ __ ] zel
how many movies you still do every year
dog you know anything like look then
right I mean it's and oh no no but I'm
not asking you my brother me you're
still doing moving in no no not nearly
as much but yoga music yeah I mean one
you're the last of the Mohicans do you
survive it out in Cali we know is yeah
no look I'm lucky cuz look I'm not only
just that but you know I've gotten off
into the voice-over game you know I'm
saying like you know you know there's
got to be crafty out in this thing and
once you find out things that you know
people think you're good at you know you
have to you know try to exploit that but
you know book my to my point when and we
were talking about earlier was hey man
you know we're not you know we're we're
in this thing and we're doing our thing
but we're not that that on that that
when we know when we get to work with
legends like it doesn't mean anything
you know it means something you know it
means something that worked with Robert
De Niro you know me I told you I you you
know you're talking about Robert De Niro
I said I said I got geek I got fleeky
when I worked with Paul Sorvino thank
you doesn't mean there's just certain
people just some of them to it yeah me
but you don't you know
like you and me like there's certain
people like they use like y'all but you
know me you know are you doing some with
your born you look like you know you
know and that's and get to me I think
that's one of the cool things about I
got like I don't want to do that you
know you ever see these old jaded as
[ __ ] been in there too long
like nothing gets them excited anymore
you know I mean like you're mean like no
disrespect but but I used to really love
Richard Jeni you know I mean me and
Richard Jeni was like a really funny
dude thing but every time do but you
know as long as I've got Richie Rich you
know obviously you know he got to a
point where like you don't like [ __ ] was
making them happy anymore like even even
when good stuff happens you know I mean
I like and then you get together
absolutely anything means good dude and
I really could do to me but Rachel you
don't and rotameter
like you know saying like when you get
to that point when you know even you
like you get the unit opportunity and
and then you you know like all you get a
pilot or something in the island and not
that it's gonna work you know then then
what then what are we doing what are we
doing it for like I still I still get
excited about stuff that happens in our
business you know what I mean like it's
fun like you know me kicking a hit with
you man me and you ain't kids in a long
time
that [ __ ] is fun you don't mean I didn't
do nothing I didn't do anything today
you know I worked I worked all weekend
me and play head shows over the weekends
man I got back here I didn't do [ __ ]
today but I drank champagne and I got I
got a mani-pedi you know like that you
know you know same wish and that's what
we're very close because that's because
me and you used to do the Brea improv on
Tuesdays and Wednesday night unless you
really know how many Sebastien
sustainable you nothing but you later
what they don't know for me I gotta be
honest with you I wake up every morning
and I'm happy I'm still here and they're
not happy that I'm still here yeah she
don't say I'm like I ain't gotta cleanse
anymore wait but look look at him [ __ ]
this guy like me
San Jose California and used to do is
stand upright and carry right either
store do you think you [ __ ] people
baffle I'm baffled wait and we're
talking about look and people think like
and I don't I don't want you know you
know me like not you know you know
loving the Comedy Store whatever like
that I don't want anybody to get it
twisted
I don't want anybody get it twisted like
like it's not like it's not a
prestigious place we so yeah do we don't
have talks clubs I don't know what I'm
telling you I don't want all day okay
all these Polly's might not yeah I know
your Polly I do nothing wrong nothing
and if you really think I mean that
place is one of the preeminent place you
look and but this is where this is where
we came because this is the stuff at its
highest level is the Comedy Store if you
live right in front it's really improv
you know it's that you know it's the you
know and there's improv dotted all
around here and there's cool rooms you
know somebody does something cool they
do they man my man I'm Adam hunter I've
been out of town but he's been trying to
get me to come over there are there at
the dime you know Chappelle when I went
over to that spot like man they you know
they doing school stuff all over town
man you know how that goes we just you
know we're not we're not as young as we
used to be but we used to we used to hit
all those bikes and all those Latins by
trust me those Latin spots helped me
become oh Jesus crime ik [ __ ] yeah
because they were they were the most
plentiful out here in Southern
California right transistor store just
man they sure you know what no I still
am in I still do stuff with um Robert
Zapata Sebastian you know I haven't done
something for Rudy in a minute but yeah
I mean you know guy I mean how many
times you know I haven't spoke to him in
a minute but Rick Martinez god I used to
do [ __ ] without you to three joints
within a week
he's melting up I think he kind of I
don't know I heard from it or from time
to time yes
yeah you know he does something for ya
man you know look man god bless you know
God bless those Latin dudes that was a
hustling no no they were hugging so that
we can you know you just when you all
make them live it like you say when [ __ ]
was low yeah you need that fifth I was
gonna be there any fun these guys
whatever yeah that's that money that's
that money put in the gas to get back
the [ __ ] to LA they would have 40 to do
their show in Whittier I used to a
bowling in here oh I am bowling alley
and bowling alley and witty [ __ ] I
mean you name it people you don't think
and I and I was just glad today came
from here to play in a bowling alley in
Whittier Sunday I'm known as day every
[ __ ] week imma do it you were out
there doing two mexican gigs
it didn't matter you drive anywhere Lee
so here tortillas we get stoned we see
Philippe Willy Garcia we see [ __ ]
people
every goddamn week and then you end up
either at the improv the store it was
just [ __ ] a different Hill and I wish
I wish at times I still had the stamina
it is you're right about a I'll you
right about five nights a week you right
about that you know what it is we're but
guess what you know we got to take
advantage of it like you know I like on
the list to boot it like you know I'm
saying cuz we don't got a job no more
you know what I'm saying but you're
right even even that it you still it's
hard to have the energy
cuz you used to hit like come on you
used to hit like four or five spots a
night like aha like I'm there I remember
I like Jeff Garcia used to tell me like
how many spots he here tonight like spot
spot spot spot spot but you know we're
not 32 no more serious [ __ ] you and
literally I got eight hours of sleep
last night yeah you know I got eight
hours of sleep
investment I can't do that more every
[ __ ] night yeah I worked yeah what
about it one yeah I got up at [ __ ]
eight that wasn't bad last night talk
I'm happy you came on I'm happy you go
on tour and I'm happy to get on the
[ __ ] I would say this yeah I would
say this um cats that up that interested
in catching um kitten play doing are
things in play we're still doing a lot
of those I love the 90s
dates and
like I love the 90s and I loved and I
need the party continues I think we're
at the Greek we're at the Greek in July
with TLC and genuine and a bunch of
other group so you know it's a real cool
man like you know we're you know we're
glad to still be nobody I'll show you
how many girls now just true he is to be
their specular together I said yeah yeah
we did a show with them a few months ago
like up north at a casino you know and
they they got like dancers and all kind
of things you know the kind of you know
you know why would a girl yeah you don't
think then you know they miss an
important part but you know I asked
video aspect to it and what I whatever
so I would say this I think you know if
you if you love if you love the group
TLC then you should come check it
because you know if you love the music
you're going to love the music and then
you know they pay homage to to left I
knew nothing in a way you know anything
that we left me can laugh at that your
timing is like upper water time in peril
after that we and number two I can see
the star creeping up on you might as
well take another bite you know fan it's
all over it's like that who sang that
song using who's on that song help oh
and uh just you laying around but they
did a couple different one Mary they've
lied you one well yeah you probably
figured unmarried a flies don't really
matter cuz like oh yeah just working
that way we can here this would be a do
it again
a duet is what you guys have you got
some um you got a really i got w a TW
those we got joy day as up with a quick
lava wasn't chosen but quickly we do is
to quickly lead what's going on like
like you remember that lewis one i don't
let us start what is he an orphan
is it overnight he's out of the bag of -
[ __ ] but nobody knows we're playing back
in the bag when you're right hundred
milligrams no squeal on a buddy you
gotta eat plan play aware though i know
you need that last combo yes lee what is
the problem tonight i'm too high why
isn't we do what you do man
we're gonna do Wednesday night when
Gomes comes down here and he wants to
break your record and break you got eat
you happy twenty five hundred milligrams
on Wednesday you're gonna need some
maple gummy saw first I got a star one
so [ __ ] hooking us up tomorrow you
understand me you don't have to eat
[ __ ] twenty five hundred milligrams
on Wednesday night are you prepared for
this I'm trying to pay no I think I
better laughs you think I'm a bad guy
hey you got like four most classy just
to put you in that level to prepare you
for Wednesday lady I'm just trying to
help ya I've been here you do what you
need to do but I would leave that last
up there's about what there's about six
or seven warning these goes down in two
[ __ ] handfuls look I got right yeah I
got my stuff I'll take [ __ ] three or
four million
oh wait think I'm a [ __ ] half a
[ __ ] soldier here smell this when you
smell the bag it says totally I smelled
it different ways right here it punched
me in the nose alright number one you
know I love you [ __ ] always
okay you got two options I didn't know
what was going on with me but uh I gotta
be honest with ya I started working with
Dollar Shave Club about 18 months ago
and I still use their raisins and you
know what I still have the handle
we stopped working with them and I
continue using their products I was out
of the shea butter but you know I'm
saying I still used the blades you know
why because they make sense and then
[ __ ] tremendous I love it and I made
the smarter choice by going which Dollar
Shave Club
now Dollar Shave Club is a smaller
choice get a great shave and a great
price convenience delivered
you ready deliver it right to your door
it's an awesome life hack and no-brainer
choice you no longer have to slip to the
store to buy cheap disposable razors
eleven that no one's not going to give
you a cheap shave I spent a fortune on
razors with gimmicky shaving you don't
need and when I use my DSC executive
razor with the dr. Carver's shea butter
forget about it the blade gently slides
giving me a smudge smoother shave listen
him you're not using dr. carve the shea
butter you don't even understand how
great this stuff is it's transparent
more precise shave and hubs prevent
ingrown hair and it elicits that's right
and it fights razor humps you too can
make the smarter choice by joining
Dollar Shave Club right now and I'm
gonna tell you what I'm going to do for
you fathers days coming to do I'll tell
you what I'm going to do for right now
limited time only new members get the
first month of the executive razor what
was a tool of dr. kaar the shea butter
for only five hours with you ready for
this
come on free shipping I'm ready and
after that the razor is just a few bucks
a month come on that's a $15 value free
shipping five bucks every favorite and
your first month box you got an awesome
waiting handle you get a full cassette
of four cartridges and a tube of the
shave brothers you understand me because
after the first month replacement
cartridges
ship automatically at their regular
price will you shipping them down by the
docks
the beauty is there's no hidden fees and
no commitments you cancel anytime just
what I like no commitment no commitment
like oh my all my relations
now you can get only this offer at
Dollar Shave Club by going Dollar Shave
Club / Church again that's
dollarshaveclub.com / Church again that
dollarshaveclub.com / Church I'll try
that I'm gonna give you the first month
of the executive razor the tube of dr.
Carla shea butter that's only 5 hours
with free shipping right to your door
I gotta go to dollarshaveclub.com you
know a shirt you know who likes dollars
a plant food Barry why he's dead what
are you gonna do you know say I'm gonna
do my baby well don't be doing Barry
White or later save it for the [ __ ]
open the other side maybe you don't know
Barry weathers you might educated
assured that sing him a song a whole
[ __ ] jealousy let me explain something
to you people MBT watch em VMT watches
was founded on the belief that the style
shouldn't break the bank
okay the watchmakers goal is to change
the way the consumers think about the
fashion by offering high-quality
minimalistic products at the
revolutionary price with over a million
watches sold a million the customers of
160 countries around the world every
empty watches as solidified itself as
the world's fastest-growing watch
company all right Lee loves his watch
I've seen people complement Lee on this
Black Watch is beautiful it isn't at it
no problems at all it's still ticking it
feels good on them he enjoys it people
comment on what he's going to do and
this is how you get started alright this
is a company designed by do broke
college kids that wanted to wear stylish
watches but couldn't of water so they
start their own watch company and this
is they started with grassroots well
just like us you know saying YouTube
podcasts radio et cetera there's what
I'm going to do for you movement wants
to start at 95 hours now these same
watches the department store you're
looking at 4 to 500 bucks
movement figured out that by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail market
providing the best possible price you
had classic designs your quality
construction and you have style
development of minimalism over 1 million
watches sold in over 60 countries ok
listen what I'm going to do today right
now I'm going to give you 15% off with
free shipping and free returns by going
M VMT watches calm slash Church CHEO r
CH again mbm T watches calm slash Church
15% off today with free shipping and if
for any problem free returns and they'll
send it right back to you anyway
MVM t watches comms last Joey
I want to thank MB Mt I want to thank
dollarshaveclub.com I want to thank my
man Chris watery Johnny [ __ ] singer
why Bronx New York and I want to thank
my little Jewish [ __ ] camera me yes
Oh have you what he have to don't forget
I'll see you [ __ ] Thursday
alone
8 o'clock I house I'm just working out
$10 one hour come on down you're not
doing this one more comfy cocoa start
your party I'm in love with the coke oh
Jesus why don't you go out on that I
love you [ __ ] it was gone that
soon hit it I'm in love with go right oh
you go no what am I
yay roses awesome gap awesome gap
I enjoy the process of bonus show what
they go for and I got it made like
Johnny Canuck got a stand-up christening
no man fatal and three ready exam party
party and have a good time all I need is
a partner
holy simple they might say the down the
pace down red tonight looking the
positive pull up idea what the hot babe
is right here to assist or party some
kind whole set I would buy my crisps on
the ballroom and the my dessert man I'm
gonna have fun
[Music]
okay
[Music]
looking for more there goes the dance
floor check your coat and your come with
at the door because before you're gonna
get last day the pile of the work be
miles away
the whole thing is matter for the good
times that can be had with the help of a
good rock did you say tight wasn't up to
par oh oh there goes a cutie in the boss
[Music]
music Christ in the bow right with you I
wouldn't know kid baby to make noise you
and your girl - me and my boy just
feeling like the night goes pleasure
no question enough and you walk this
will be a night you'll kick and that's a
promise me you my hand here you say oh
what a black kid so many good fun
walking laughs come on out Fred hit the
scam next we're gonna do it again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]